president Trump's nominees for Secretary
of State and CIA director are facing
uphill confirmation battles today the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee is
expected to vote against current CIA
director Mike Pompeo to become Secretary
of State and the president's choice to
replace Pompeo deputy CIA director Gina
Haspel also faces tough opposition her
role in destroying 92 tapes of terror
suspects being interrogated after 9/11
he is under scrutiny Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning those destroyed tapes are a big
source of concern for senators from both
sides as they weigh her nomination but
the CIA has been pushing back hard
releasing a Declassified 2011 memo to
show that hospital was cleared of any
wrongdoing
regarding those tapes now this memo was
written by then Deputy Director Mike
Morell who is now a CBS News contributor
he said Haspel did draft a cable
directing that the tapes be destroyed
but only because her supervisor ordered
her to still more than 100 retired
generals and admirals are sending a
letter to Congress today calling
hospitals torture record quote troubling
the letter says we do not accept efforts
to excuse her actions relating to
torture and other unlawful abuse of
detainees by offering that she was just
following orders now as for the current
CIA director Mike Pompeo all the
Democrats on the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee plus Kentucky
Republican Rand Paul are set to vote
against him for Secretary of State
later today but even if the committee
vote fails there are still ways for
Republicans to bring his nomination to
the full Senate for a vote and if all
Republicans or at least most of them
hang together he can still get confirmed
gale thanks Nancy